die amerikanische botschaft in berlin
wie immer streng bewacht jede
us-vertretung ist jetzt ein potenzielles
ziel einen krieg verhindern dass fordert
die bundesregierung also zurückhaltung
auf beiden seiten mit besonnenheit und
zurückhaltung zu einer deeskalation
beizutragen das amerikanische vorgehen
ist eine reaktion auf eine ganze reihe
von militärischen provokationen wie die
der iran verantwortung trägt die
beziehungen zwischen usa und iran sind
seit 40 jahren schlecht die jüngste
krise nahm ihren lauf im mai 2018
us-präsident trump kündigte das atom
abkommen mit iran auf nennt es den
schlechtesten deal aller zeiten und
verhängt schwere wirtschaftssanktionen
im juni 2009 10 dann explosionen auf
zwei tanker im golf von oman
die usa machen iran verantwortlich
ebenfalls im juni schießt iran eine us
spionage drohne vom himmel
das pentagon reagiert empört die drohne
sei in internationalem luftraum geflogen
september 2009 10 die größte
ölraffinerie saudi arabiens geht in
flammen auf
die usa die traditionell das saudische
königshaus unterstützen vermuten iran
dahinter wir haben gewissermaßen schon
einen krieg im jahr 2020 werden kriege
anders geführt als noch vor 20 jahren
oder vor 30 jahren es gibt verschiedene
anschläge hier und da es gibt
verschiedene operationen durchgeführt
werden wirtschaftssanktionen
cyberangriffe und wir sind mittendrin
die frage ist nur wie weiter geht es in
der eskalation wir haben ein neues level
erreicht
und so beobachten sie in berlin und auf
der ganzen welt wann und wie iran
antwortet